or so here's how this went down just got
back from Los Angeles filmed a bunch of
movie games it was a lot of fun I'm beat
I'm tired I get home and my Twitter's
like hey new Assassins Creed movie
trailer I was like I'll do it tomorrow
I'm really tired and now it's tomorrow's
now we're doing it well first off this
video is of course brought to you by
loot crate because this is a YouTube
video that's kind of how it works now
the thing this month though is power
which sounds pretty awesome the movie
Crowell says power is fleeting love is
eternal I find that to be [ __ ] power
is pretty [ __ ] rad more on that later
let's talk about some Assassin's Creed
nonces not actually nonsense I actually
thought the trailer was pretty they made
some changes and changes that I liked
tanja music is not one of those changes
I actually that's one of the ones I
don't like because there is no artist
that I abhor more than Kanye West that
aside though the trailer actually got me
more pumped for the movie one because
the Kanye music or not it's not [ __ ]
dubstep it's not that stupid and two
they made some changes from the video
game to the movie that's one of the
challenges that video game adaptations
to movies make is that they try to just
retell the same old story when people
heard that Michael Fassbender was going
to be the assassin we were like he's
whitewashing is racism done actually
because he plays a guy in the Spanish
Inquisition that's the freedom they have
is he's his own guys and new characters
so they can make up a story for him and
not just copy and paste the story from
the games unless he's actually from the
later games I honestly stopped playing
Assassin's Creed after Desmond's story
wrapped up was like alright the story
wrapped up and it's gonna keep going
though because they want to make more
games
I heard Black Flag was actually really
cool as a pyro game I just haven't
played it so here we are in a world
where I am completely under the
impression that Michael Fassbender's
character is completely new to the
Assassin's Creed universe but the cool
thing about it is as Michael
Fassbender's characters going through
his thing
desmond miles from the game could be
going through his thing they could be
parallels to each other they can
complement each other the movie doesn't
override the game i think that's a good
move and you see some cool Assassin's
Creed [ __ ] that we actually know you
know Abstergo gets there they hook him
up to the thing is like vr troopers and
[ __ ] and then he re-enacts his ancestors
like killings that is you know the knife
that Leonardo da Vinci made which still
happened that's what I'm talking about
it is a little different in this one
though when I was playing
Sanskrit I just remember they hooked up
Desmond to the thing like the matrix and
he just laid there and got all the
knowledge so his muscle memory
remembered it so he got more athletic
but he didn't actually do the
athleticism and this one's like fast
Bender's hooked up to this thing that
grabs him by the waist and as he is
going through the city in the virtual
reality world in the past he's actually
acting it out in this huge room Abstergo
they got a budget that's a bit different
it could be pretty sweet it's not gonna
add or take away from anything in the
end you just hooked up to a thing and
then he's you know in the cool world
that we want to Z we had some brief
trailer honest I just want to show you
that hey if you're a fan of the game
you'll probably like the movie because
it has everything that you want but it
also has Michael Fassbender Marion
Cotillard and Alfred like-new Alfred
kind of more hardcore out Jeremy Irons
voices scar I don't know how many
references I can make to properly
illustrate the Jeremy Irons is pretty
rad as long as I never reference that
Dungeons & Dragons movie I think you
will be there but really it's kind of a
cinematography showcase there's a lot of
imagery in this trailer that's taken
right from the game it's better when he
jumps off of the building even the way
he curls to land in the hey I'm like yep
that's how you land in this asin's great
the acting talent is there the premise
is there it looks like the atmospheres
there - the Kayne music I hope that's
not in there anymore than the dubstep is
in the Warcraft movie and they're
actually making another story a separate
story from Desmond Miles so they have
the freedom to do their own thing
without actually butchering lore to it
they can still butcher lore on this one
considering Abstergo they could do it
I'm just saying it's less likely it
looks like they don't want to that's the
only reason you would do that is so you
don't so if they do they shot themselves
in the dick and they're all just dumb
shits all in all pretty good for the
first trailer like a two minute to user
trailer but 2016 is the year guys if
these video game movies aren't good then
they should stop trying forever alright
guys so the Assassin's Creed movie
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it are you excited are you
scared do you think it's gonna work
whatever you think comment below let me
know and remember this video is brought
to you by loot crate the may loot
crate's theme is power you have until
the 19th to enter promo code Jeremy John
save yourself ten percent and get the
crate theme of
where is that weird is can we make it a
little more awkward there we go
it's not that awkward and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more